When finding the sum of polynomials, we want to identify like terms first. I
have 3x squared y squared, and negative 14, x squared, y squared, these are
like-terms because they're the same variables with the same exponents. Negative
8xy and negative 2xy are also like terms, so I can list those together, down
here. These last two terms are tricky, they're actually not like, so I can only
list them separately, I won't be able to combine them, or add them. Now I simply
count up the number of x squareds y squared that I have, I have positive 3 and
negative 14 of them, so that's a total of negative 11. For the next term, I have
negative 8xy, and negative 2xy, so that makes negative 10xy altogether. And
finally, we just list these terms as sums on the end, because they're not like
with anything else in our expression, so here's our answer.